[Musique]
les shadoks ont pompé tout long de la
planète à eau puis il la repompe pour la
remettre en place mon pays pour les
shadoks à la longue
c'était devenu une habitude c'est à la
pompe en effet que la plupart de leurs
travaux s'effectuent et ne sais c'est
que tu es pas ça demande quand les
shadoks eux se trouvaient devant un
grave problème est qu'il voyait pas très
bien comment faire eh bien il pompe est
de toute façon il disait ça pouvait pas
nuire
il avait de grosses pompes pour les gros
problèmes et des p'tites poules pour les
petits problèmes
il avait mis au point aussi des pompes
spéciale pour les cas où il n'y avait
pas de problème du tout pour ceux de nos
téléspectateurs que la technique
intéresse disons que quand on pompait
avec ça non seulement il ne se passait
rien comme avec une pompe shadoks
ordinaire mais plus on comptait et plus
il n'y avait rien qui se passait c'était
quand même une sécurité
il dit que le chemin que j'ai fini de
pomper les jbe leur envoyer des visions
les shadoks croyez voir la terre est
illégal est en réalité c'était n'importe
quoi comme par exemple la planète molle
mais les shadoks pensais que c'était
uniquement un problème de mou alors une
pompe est le mou avec leurs pompes à
problèmes nous et pendant que les
shadoks aller comme ça de fausses terme
faut se taire les jib y aller
s'installer tranquillement sur la vraie
[Musique]